the olympics are going on
in tokyo hardcore now there's a familiar
face that has been
at the olympics since 2004 who is not
there competing for the men's
swimming team ryan lochte is joining us
now
from his home in in florida and ryan
thanks so much for joining me
number one and number two this is just
like uncharted territory for you
watching the olympics instead of being
there what is what has it been like so
far for you as you uh kind of segue into
this new role
uh it's so weird i'm not gonna lie i'm
not gonna sugarcoat it either i'm pissed
i'm sad it's just weird because you know
the past
four olympics for 16 years straight
i've been at the big show
and me not being there and watching like
the team usa
like swim i'm just like this is so weird
watching it from my living room like
yeah i'm usually right there on the pool
deck
cheering my teammates on and now i'm not
it's very weird
um it's 17 years i mean it's
unbelievable i mean
it's almost got to be surreal for you
because you were competing with these
guys
like a month ago as you were you know
trying to make this olympic team
and now you've had to turn into this big
cheerleader for them does it make you
want to like stay competitive i mean a
lot of people would think man you've
been doing this for so long
you're so accomplished with 12 olympic
medals and all the world records you've
set
but does this keep the hunger alive for
competing
um in a way it does um
but in a way it's like
i don't know it's just a weird feeling
like i wake up in the morning
and i'm just like scratching my head
like
what do i do now like i don't have to go
to the pool and train
like i don't have any swim meets coming
up so i'm just like wait a minute
i guess i can uh mow the yard again
i just did that yesterday i'll do it
again today
like i'm just finding like um stuff to
do around the house
uh it's a weird feeling um but you know
watching swimming it's like
i definitely start noticing that i do
want to get back involved
like i want to be involved in the sport
no matter what whether it's
competing or you know trying to
build the sport of swimming making it
bigger than what it is right now